[Musique]
les cas ça me sont déjà à vis de la vie
si tous kankan est astucieux peine
le plus sérieux à jouer il suffit de
vouloir devenir ami fabrice je ne suis
qu'un volatiles migy plein d'idées dans
c'est vrai un bon et tué un beau
volatile et oui oui dont on joue au jeu
du pays aux jeux de la géographie la
géographie dames 1 alors toujours trois
éléments toujours trois éléments le
premier le second le 3e bien joaillier
la forme du pays le oui bon le drapeau
et le troisième bonjour dans la langue
du pays
le touriste a h1n1
le tout sur ce tableau sur ce tableau ya
la fleure bon tu deviens découvre le
premier élément le contour du pays le
contour du pays
à gauche du tableau c'est plus difficile
que la semaine dernière à je te préviens
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe thiaroyois oui c'est
pas commodes en bois tout de même
regarde c'est un pays assez
caractéristique ce n'est pas ça je suis
dans mes petits souliers quand je vois
ça bon l'autre élément oui le drapeau de
ce pays le drapeau de ce pays
le voilà le gratin pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la couleur
il s'agit là du verre du blanc et du
rouge
alors maintenant bonjour dans la langue
de ce pays bonjour dans la langue du
pays riz
buongiorno we are both as s'apprête à
l'imagination
écoute je crois quand même que tous nos
amis savent très bien que l'inde
voisin à cette forme de la botte 1 ça
ressemble à une bonne ça c'est l'italie
tout simplement ni reçues plus d'une
fois dans les plumes à brigitte existait
une chance alors voilà l'italie voilà
son drapeau et banjo qui veut dire
bonjour voila tu pars format d'efforts a
le droit d'aller dans le jardin j'y vais
madame jardin c'est l'été c'est les
vacances alors vas t'amuser
eh ben je vais en profiter absolument ce
temps là nous on prépare le jeu du point
commun du cac à willy tient au courant
bien dit de quoi oui bien sûr toujours
bon la pjj fabre et oui va bien j'arrive
à témoin
g arrive haussier que bonjour rapidos
bonjour ici et moi je reviens oui oh oui
mais merde fils elle est tout le temps
derrière tes bottes à wisches et pas bon
ne perdons pas tant le point commun
alors je rappelle tout de même si vous
le voulez bien que le point commun est
un point commun vous avez entre vous oui
elle est où je veux dire ce que vous
êtes la nourrit trouver tous ensemble
quel est le point commun à l'étoile a
pas d'accord ce marché commence à temps
encore oui alors bon chez moi il ya des
gens très sérieux qui se rassemble ils
sont très sérieux et très nombreux
d'ailleurs ils viennent de toutes les
régions de france ils viennent discuter
de problèmes très importants ils
viennent même parler de ce qu'on va
apprendre en classe 57 dire si c'est
sérieux c'est drôle d'ailleurs car quand
on les voit tous ces gens on dirait
qu'ils sont en classe ils sont derrière
leur pupitre ils ont des cahiers des
stylos tout ça ils prennent des notes
edgar quelquefois y crie très fort mais
très fort et kalanga ya un surveillant
qui les attrape
voilà et qui l'ont dit sauter voilà je
la trouvais des gentils bah non c'est
pas facile là j'attends un petit peu je
ressens lorsque bell bell
oui moi ont plumé trouvait dans un
appartement on me trouve même dans tous
les appartements
c'est un endroit que j'aime beaucoup et
dans lequel je passe une bonne partie de
mon existence chacun de nous possède un
endroit de ce genre j'ai fait peindre le
mien dans des couleurs très clair
j'ai placé des tableaux des photos qui
me rappelle de beaux souvenirs
cet endroit est fait pour le repos il
doit être éloigné du bruit en amour il
faut qu'il soit nous y est tu brasses je
crois que je commence à avoir une idée
pour ce monsieur aubin moi moi qui suis
je
je ne suis pas aussi élégant que ce que
vient de déclarer belle bella non non
non non non non non je suis bien plus
beau des stries mais je suis très utile
pour certaines personnes mais je pense
aux aux automobilistes en particulier
mais seulement pour que je puisse leur
rendre service pour que je leur
permettent de rouler il me faut de l'air
arvesen si j'ai pas d'air ce alors je ne
suis qu'une pauvre chose alors sans
former et sans valeur mais lors des
comptes donne de l'air
alors à moi à moi les cyclistes à moi
les motocyclistes les automobilistes je
vais leur faire dévorer des kilomètres
cuba oui je crois que ça y est cette
fois ci il me semble bien que je
trouvais le point commun qui vous unit
tout le monde
en principe tout concorde après la
description devait devrait être la
chambre des députés
l'esp à la chambre des députés
qu'on l'appelle aujourd'hui l'assemblée
nationale a approuvé doit juste une
chambre simplement d'un appartement oui
enfin je suis c'est une chambre à air
chambre et voilà
résidant à alors est formidable cette
forme est là elle belle tu sais que tu
dois travailler maintenant c'est très
très intéressant je vais ou non non non
pas dans ce cas vidéo s'il te plait je
t'en remercie si tu permets qu'on
continue à des choses à faire doit à sa
venue
les bell labs je ne laisse puisque je
vais aller préparer notre petit jeu
musical bon troisième poser en brasse
hommes avec à leur bord voire bon à la
saisie mois pousse mousse lui
oui j'ai l'impression que c'est à tous
ah oui ça va être à nous alors alors tu
sais ce qui se passe d'habitude le
rideau graff de faire attention et ben
je te demande de faire attention les
hivers tu es prêt oui je suis prêt bon
vivre aux costumes et bien écoute je ne
sais pas si ton tableau va être assez
large parce que bon oui c'est à un mot
en onze lettres
bon cela qui commence pas qu'ils
commencent par un n 1 n 1 c'est bien sûr
de toi oui un aimant après je fais alors
tu fais neuf titres eh oui comme
d'habitude 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 dernières
lettres 1n accord encore oui encore à
neige à est maintenant à toi je t'écoute
est ce que c'est une fleur à no no no
man s que c'est un arbre non non plus
alors c'est un animal oui c'est un
animal parce que ça ce sont les trois
sujets qu'il adore voilà bon 1 1 à nîmes
un gros animal lui aussi enfin moyens
gay il est bien qui est assez les plus
grands que moi oui on voit ça c'est pas
difficile à bruce moussu est ce que
c'est un animal que nous trouvons dans
les forêts françaises par exemple
non non non non ne n'y en a pas en
france mont ou alors très peu vraiment
henry vraiment je peux te dire qu'il a
quatre pattes
il a quatre appuis la cata et n'est pas
il n'habite pas en france la vie de
pauvres est ce que c'est un animal qui
rampe au nom non ils rendent pas non est
ce que c'est un animal qui sautent a de
temps en temps il faut dans tripoli sans
qu'il y ait ce qu'il peut courir
ah oui tu veux que je te donne la
troisième lettre
j'aimerais bien avoir été des oui oui à
la troisième lettre c'est un l'air 1er
mai la troisième lettre et la troisième
est qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que
ça est ce que c'est c'est est ce que
c'est un animal qui cas des poils la wii
wheel année poil oui oh oui est ce que
c'est un animal qui existent en afrique
oui oui 9 les hommes étaient bien qu est
ce qu il a des mains ah oui là oui oui
de pathé pieds et des mains
c'est pas un sage celui-ci site a trouvé
c'est un sage
bah si c'est un singe ailleurs bon il
pourra y avoir quoi c'est pas possible
tu m'aurais pas fait une chose pareille
c'est pas un orang outan ainsi un orang
outan comment un orang outan m'étais
créé un orang outan avec un alaoui avec
un n 1 jour
bah oui enfin pouces moussu c'est la
liaison c'est un orang outan chez la
liaison moi je te suis assez gris comme
gilles et propose ça s'écrit comme ça on
rend comme ça en main et puis en plus tu
m'aurais pu dire qu'il y avait un trait
d'union et il y as après ou temps t elle
à peine un orang outan écoute a lâché
plein de choses
c'est pas croyable pas de changer pas de
choses parce que moi j'étais bien
content d'avoir appris qu'on ne mettait
pas de jets à la fin alors moi je crois
que tu allais me féliciter et puis voilà
craque je me suis encore à 31
tant pis pour toi puisque c'est comme ça
je te laisserai pas parlé on sait tous
on va retrouver bell bell tout de suite
s'est disputée en lalala d'ailleurs de
faire croire qu'on va retrouver bell
bundy
[Musique]
la fabrique des jouets avec moi
c'est la musique est à genou droit a
sacrée belle belle ta crise oui je veux
bien que nous jouions à notre petit jeu
des notes de musique mais je te préviens
je suis une mère on est énervé quand ça
se fait ça je suis entrée de match il
bâtir une birmanie nuit que ce volet là
je crois qu'il a eu
l'indre on joue tout c'est à leurs
ennemis qu'il connaît notre jeu alors
moi je vais te dire une chose si tu me
parles de cylindres je mettrais ainsi
parce qu'avec un être si nous avons les
voitures à six cylindres
tia koné déchirure qui se meurt oui et
puis c'est modère les confortables ces
deux voitures
elle possède des sièges réglables
mais quoi bi mais en fait il y en a
comme titre
tout ça avant je dois tu trouves cette
pub de musique ça fait vide ancien oui
les dossiers mais bien sûr des vingt ans
il est réglable grâce au moteur il y
très lancieux corbas silencieux wee et
troublant si tu sais je ne sais pas
exactement à quoi ça sert mais là des
espèces de club à iode
as tu veux parler des des farios l'airé
des phares à yoff
oui et puis on est bien dedans le
chauffage qu'il y ait un système à sa
gauche tous les deals ou leap qui trouve
le ci devant les stations lemay va c'est
pas grave système s'il a la possibilité
il y a pas un élu mais tom gars tu dois
pas t'en servir beaucoup un temps parce
que je ne fume pas qu'à bien raison
retrouver oui cigare un allume cigare
oui oui oui et on m'a dit aussi qu'il y
avait
j'ai pas trouvé exactement un truc qui
s'appelle inventis lutter suis là pour
toi là tu viens nous dérangeait locaux
du titre a dû jouer ou double et a
produit six écoles sera avec silva tir
on me remarque que j'irai fermé comme
sion t'es quoi des commissions de
commissions le voilà mais il faut quand
même que je passe mon nom
attends je recommande que je passe mon
père abattant j'avais fait tomber note
ça tombe bien dans ton permis si ça
exhalant des leaders et eepad ans il est
très mignon
il est quoi il est très bon je les salue
très mignon diminue encore amusée elle a
apprécié fini et bah c'est ringard c'est
idiot ni bas chez panda on va écouter ce
que ça donne parce qu'on a fait une
petite mélodie là alors nous avons ici
dont 6
c'est quoi ça ce magazine
c'est merveilleusement l'est ça tu te
joindre à notre chance au numéro 6
alonso très bien bien avec moi chanter
notre chanson l'état pousse à me sont
déjà qu'on peut pas les amis et cap sa
vidéo tu veux pas que la vie
les désistements et g shock se déchausse
pour les comme juni pas de minois
il faudra faire attention les quatre
amis sont partagés sont réunis les gars
ça me sont heureux car c'est la vie
oui
joël abati
paris
aujourd'hui etc
si le vouloir revenir à un ami il suffit
de vouloir devenir amis
ouais eh oui
[Musique]
question